Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. I wish I could come
to you today and say good people of my audience
remember that little COVID blip last week I told
you about that little 10 percent pop in cases. It
was nothing. Cases are back down. I wish I could
tell you that and I could, but I would be lying,
and I make every effort not to lie to you
on this program because cases are back up
again and cases are now back up in the United
States. Cases are up even more globally, and we
don't know the trajectory here. There are models
saying this is the beginning of another disaster.
There are models saying there will be a brief
spike into sort of January, and then it's going to
be a big, big, big decline, the permanent decline,
the final decline, quite frankly. There have been
models indicating everything for almost two years
now. And some of them happen to come across the
correct explanation, but there is very little
consistency in which models those are. So I think
we do not know the direction that this is going.
And of course, the situation is dynamic in the
sense that where it goes will depend on what we
do. But let's look at where the numbers are today
in the United States, dating back to the end of
October. Cases have climbed 16 percent from 71000
cases a day to 83000 cases a day. Now we've been
dancing here between 60 and 100000 cases a day
for a very long time to really get this to the
point where we would consider it based on public
health expert assessments, epidemiologists,
et cetera, really get this under control.
10000 cases a day is the number that is
being discussed. It has been a really long
time since we were even remotely close to that
as as if the U.S. numbers aren't bad enough.
Globally, cases have climbed even more 22 percent
from their bottom of about 400000 COVID cases a
day in the middle of October. Now up 22 percent
to close to 500000 cases a day globally. Half
a million COVID cases that we know about globally
and we know we're not capturing nearly every COVID
case with a positive test. Now, if there's any OK
news so far, it's that again, for now in the U.S.,
deaths are still not ticking up along with the
cases. However, you've probably heard me say this
100 times now. It often takes three to four weeks
for deaths to follow what cases do. So we have to
look out for that. But for now, deaths continuing
down. They peaked during Delta around 2000 a day.
They're now down to less than half of that under
a thousand deaths a day. That's a very good thing.
However, if we look at the global trend where
the case spike started about two weeks before
it started in the U.S., deaths are increasing
just a bit up about five six percent. So it's
not a disaster yet globally in terms of the death
increase. We do need to wait two to three more
weeks to see if the death increase is going to
follow here in the United States. What's the hope?
The hope is we have enough vaccination
combined with recovered immunity
that cases and deaths start to become decoupled,
we've talked about this before. If everyone is
vaccinated, a case means a lot less in terms of
how likely it is to lead to a hospitalization and
subsequently lead to a death. The hope would be
we are vaccinated enough, we have enough immunity
that cases will go up without deaths going
up. It's really not apparent that that's
the case right now. Fifty eight point eight
percent of the country is fully vaccinated,
call it 59 percent. You then have to add to that
people with some level of immunity despite being
unvaccinated because they've recovered from COVID.
We know that can be hard to predict. How long does
that last? How robust is it? But officially, there
have been 48 million cases in the U.S. now. You
can't just say, add 48 million. Why? Well, a lot
of those 48 million people have been vaccinated,
so they're actually in both groups. At the same
time, some of the people that have recovered have
immunity that may have waned completely by now
at the same time. There are people who don't even
show up in the number of 48 million U.S. cases at
all because they never got a test. But they have
some immunity, so we just don't know what number
to add. Let's imagine that to the 58 percent that
are vaccinated, we can add 40 million total.
That's like 12 percent of the U.S. So maybe
right now we're at 70 percent of the population,
72 percent of the population with some immunity
today that may not be enough
to decouple cases and deaths.
But maybe we're starting to get close. It does
seem in the midst of all this that third doses are
coming for everybody. There's a report from Axios
that the Biden administration is expected to start
the booster expansion process to authorize third
doses to all adults, potentially as early as this
week could be. Today could be tomorrow could be
Friday. That's according to a source familiar with
the internal planning. As I told you guys on the
bonus show, etc. I got my third dose on Thursday,
and it does seem as though third doses are likely
coming for everybody who has been following
the recommendations on vaccination. Obviously,
people who haven't gotten dose one or dose two
are not going to get those three because that's
just not how it works. So that's the latest. As
far as COVID is concerned, we're going to continue
following these numbers. Let's hope that next week
heading into Thanksgiving, we have something so
something that looks better. Oh, people again,
people have been asking me, What am I doing?
As far as Thanksgiving goes? I'm going to go
to Thanksgiving gathering where everybody will be
tested on the way in and everybody is vaccinated
and feels pretty safe to me, feels pretty safe
to everybody involved. And so that is my plan.
I know we have a poll on our YouTube Community
tab right now that you can vote in where you can
if you are doing Thanksgiving. If you're in the
U.S., what is the vaccination policy there? Is it
proof required? Is it? It's a request,
but not a requirement, is it? You know,
whatever you can let us know and we'll have
those results coming to you very, very soon.